right this is ytterbium again the
lanthanide stored in a very old glass
bowl you terbium is there one of three
lanthanides which was named after a
swedish town called Euterpe which is
where they were all discovered terbium
erbium and terbium all derivatives of
that town named towns done well out of
it was another town stood very well out
of it yeah
have you been there no not personally
you go yeah I should yeah
it's quite moving and quite quite
stirring to be here in this place
because this is where science and an
industry came together for one of the
one of the earliest times I suppose and
a quite a significant place of discovery
and and an economic vibrancy for the
local area it's um it's almost spiritual
it's really quite quite different though
you terbium it's it well it depends on
whether you talk about the metal or as
an element and often you terbium two
compounds are sort of yellows and
oranges where do I get it from buy it
from a catalogue so ytterbium it's a
rare earth element it's a metal it's a
silvery lustrous metal it's very soft
and it reacts very readily with oxygen
to form a very nice protective oxide
layer which sits over the metal so it
preserves itself after reaction with
oxygen it was first identified or first
isolated from a sample of a mineral
which was recovered from this very
quarry where we are in it to be near
Stockholm in Sweden but it took a very
very long time to make that extraction
and to purify the metal it's a it's a
rare earth element it's one of 15 and
it's actually the least abundant of the
rare earths but the name rare earth sort
of makes you think that it's really rare
but if you look at its occurrence in the
Earth's crust it was a surprise to find
that actually it's twice as abundant as
tin but that said total production of
ytterbium is only 50 tonnes per year so
it's still very very little utilized and
that's probably because it's chemistry
is least understood and it's least
understood because we were only really
able to isolate significant amounts of
ytterbium in the in the late 1950s like
many other rare earth elements its main
applications lie in the electronics
industry it's used as a as a dopant for
phosphorus it's used as a dopant in
ceramic capacitors and other electronic
devices so to really really niche
applications
research is broadening those
applications day on day the medal itself
is really quite unusual because its
properties change as a function of
pressure so it's a metal sweeter
conductor but when you push it under
extreme pressure so fourteen thousand
that Mystery's of pressure it becomes a
semi conductor and that semi conductor
ability changes as a function of
temperature so it's used as a pressure
sensor in extreme extreme environments
and in fact one of the major
applications is in electronic devices
for the monitoring and sort of
measurement of pressure especially
within nuclear explosions so quite a
significant element and quite a recent
discovery